thank you very much
hey thanks man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
here at the uh watch your head hollywood
improv we did a crystalline friends of
the hollywood improv 10 15 on a
wednesday night funny [ __ ] i like
performing late on week days because
everyone who comes they don't have jobs
and those are the real [ __ ]
that keep this country running you know
what i mean my buddy jason is on stage
we got my boy dan right here if you can
see it
there he is
um and that's all we're doing really
crystally and friends in hollywood
improv
i love this place i love the hollywood
improv
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you've seen all his specials you watch
the podcast congratulations and all the
other ones keep it going right now mr
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you
[Applause]
uh
look hey thank you by the way you guys
are [ __ ] awesome i appreciate you
coming out give a round of applause for
everybody
[Applause]
dude you guys uh i like they asked me
though like do you want to do the 8
o'clock or the 10
or the 10 o'clock show and i was like
dude i want the [ __ ] with no
jobs coming at you
okay you don't have to wake up for [ __ ]
tomorrow
that's it
just [ __ ] chill bill man that's our
lives
the 10 15 show is going to start late
anyway
you guys are [ __ ] here we're going to
be here until 4 a.m
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
slides
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
thank you very much
hey thanks man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the worst [ __ ] superhero
[Applause]
[Music]
what's your name
[Music]
and [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
m
[Applause]
[Music]
that's crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
no pizza or something i had a pizza in
my cart
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
school guy most people think i shoot
[ __ ] out of my mouth because that is
what school is
[Music]
[Applause]
short term
[Music]
he doesn't sleep
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
you're the man bro
[Music]
[Applause]
you [ __ ] crush it dude
people are rarely standing because
you're there you're there
what do you do for a living
jobless
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not it's not because you're an
alcoholic it's because you don't answer
questions correctly
what do you do for a living i'm a
recovering alcohol
well
we're the [ __ ] star of the show
tonight bro
remember i remember i said the 10 15
show
your [ __ ] don't have jobs
[Applause]
over here leader of the [ __ ] job
[Applause]
so well you know
[Music]
what's happening
you want to come up here
[Applause]
[Music]
stay there
stay there this is working just fine
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
you're right you're right this is
[ __ ] awesome and a lot of the reason
is because you you know what man you
drive a hard [ __ ] bargain man
[Music]
[Applause]
but that's okay because it's a [ __ ]
tough market out there right
you would be both bro i don't have a job
either
you're a freelancer
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
have you ever ever
done architects or
are these people just crazy people that
live in west hollywood
[Music]
i'm an indian
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now remember dennis remember what we
learned
about three minutes ago
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are you an actual architect and you
reply
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you're an indian architect
i'm an indian so what i meant to is like
uh i'm here because i have a work visa
which means i'm into id
[Music]
so you have a work visa
so so i i i mean i think uh people need
indians you know to do fights
you know what for id jobs for id jobs
again dude
[Music]
[Applause]
one
long story my grandparents mets
how about this try to do it
medium story
jobless now
jobless now i'll call it
uh recovering
alcoholics
recovering alcoholic [ __ ] yeah dude
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's you're doing the work and i
love that man how many days
you don't mind me asking
88
[Applause]
since day one which is when this story
started here
[Music]
he used to kind of uh kind of talk i
mean introduce all of you guys no i was
sitting there
here
i i was here sitting here and the guy
who used to call you all guys you know
and the guy who what he he kind of
introduced all of you i don't know i
mean who comes comes
so now
what's happening is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i hear a lot of this stuff but then
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
dude you have no idea how much i would
[ __ ] take you up on that i would be
your friend dude i would be your friend
we would [ __ ] kill it dude we would
kill it
dude
oh
i didn't get a chance to meet him on his
birthday because like i'm recovering
alcoholic and my what did it let me go
too okay well you're looking to learn
right bro yeah yep and i had my birthday
on 24th of april yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
again i didn't talk about my age
that's just like a one word
[Applause]
you threw your arms up
and said oh
[Applause]
the [ __ ] club
oh
[Music]
you know
[Music]
well i appreciate you dude
am i going
are you gonna be trending
[Applause]
[Music]
i have a therapist
[Music]
[Applause]
it's over
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well
they have the work cut out for them
but some of mine so
i'm right there with you dude
i'm right there with you um thanks
dinesh for uh
the show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]